[Musique]
mais sert à quoi l'argent
dépenser
[Musique]
vous avez assez d'argent
ouais bien sûr combien le font 5000
francs 5000 francs par semaine et qu'est
ce que vous en faites déjà des pièces
pour mobile est déjà le reste on
sauvegarde conclut les bois qu
apparaissent des petites bricoles je
vais me [ __ ] défendu peur comme ça et
comment est-ce que vos parents vous
donne cet argent
1 comment est-ce que vos parents vous
donne cet argent moi je travaille alors
je t'aime toute ma paye puis daunay samu
feront que quatre mais cinq fois par
semaine puis je me débrouille pour masse
mais avec ce à quoi et toi au moins tu
sais quand je te demande des sous merdes
monde
c'est une récompense ce que ce qu'on te
donne une somme régulière achats locaux
chan demande si tu travailles bien ou
pas bien c'est la même chose ça n'a
aucune importance les toits des
transiliens 12 semaines ça va mais il ya
des semaines à temps et vous dépensez
votre argent comme vous le voulez
dépenser l'argent correctement quoi un
module est hongre enfin la mobylette le
centre ça les parents acceptent et qui
n'accepte pas par exemple
[Musique]
l'argent dépensé l'argent dans des cafés
alors ça c'est pas bien non non moi je
vais dans les cafés où tu fais des
économies toi tu dépenses tout et j'en
profite
jean-paul pas si tu avais à choisir
entre un métier qui te plaît nous on ne
gagne pas beaucoup d'argent est un
métier qui ne te plaît pas mais où on
gagne beaucoup d'argent qu'est-ce que tu
choisirais un métier qui me plaît puis
quelqu'un pas beaucoup d'argent est
complet oui oui c'est important d'argent
pour moi ça faire ou ce qu on aura des
pannes comme eux la parole oui c'est
important c'est important oui pourquoi
tu en as peau et ne conseille pas même
quand on fait un métier mais con
on gagne presque rien on est heureux on
dit aux gens dit on travaille mais enfin
quand on n'a pas autre chose chez toi
ali assez d'argent en ce moment pour
tellement non est ce que tu en soufre
bas un peu mais par moments passés en
mer dure parce que j'ai besoin de
quelque chose je voulais d'emprunter
auprès de fort engouement
comment tu vois l'avenir toi l'avenir
pour qui pour toi oh là là on sait rien
a peut-être mort avant n'en sais rien
tu as un métier ouais enfin si heureuse
pour un métier quoi c'est un métier son
voeu qu'est ce que c'est je suis garçons
de bureaux coursier
et quand on dépense son argent voilà
dans dans le manger dans je paye ma
chambre dans un tas de trucs quoi puis
tout seul ouais t'as quel âge j'ai 17
ans et demi du parentaide le nom va j'ai
pas de parents j'ai juste ma mère tu
aimes bien travail n'ont trahi peu je
vais avoir mon nez tu lui donnes de
l'argent et non comment fait-on pour se
débrouiller tout seul à 17 ans bah on se
débrouille trouve un boulot on trouve
une chambre
et puis et puis on se démerde ont pas eu
ma chambre on mange on se débrouille
très bien moi je trouve que c'est c'est
pas mal
bah ça il ya déjà des emmerdements d'un
côté parce que des fois on a besoin des
parents et puis des fois dont
l'épaisseur est ce que les adultes tech
c'est à dire les gens qui criaient
victoire bureau qui ont 30 ans 40 ans et
sculpteurs de presse en mairie vaivre
ouais ça m'est arrivé une fois pour
trouver une chambre on m'a aidé on m'a
prêté un peu d'argent je remboursé après
plus heureux comme tu vu ouais faut
polir colons quels sont tes plaisir
on va faire de la moto présent par
exemple parmi tant d'autres
pourquoi la moto apprécié j'aime bien
y en a qui aiment bien faire autre chose
on a quand même bien faire du sport tas
de trucs
moi j'aime bien la moto à 17 ans on a
besoin de combien d'argent pour vivre
comme tu vis dormoy bois oui probable un
besoin de beaucoup mais enfin quand on
gagne une centaine de milles on y arrive
quoi ça dépend si on a des choix à faire
sinon on y arrive à l'aise à l'aise
ouais en mangeant correctement y arrive
le principal but gérer c'est le manger
bah ouais le manger les loisirs
un peu de tout quoi les frais et les
frais divers
tout à l'heure tu te dis que tu dépenses
et où tu crois qu'il sera toujours comme
ça ah non break quand j'aurai une femme
ultra de l'économie j'essaierai c'est
une image que tu te fais de la vie
sérieuse ou est-ce que tu le pense
vraiment je croise rarement
[Musique]